>> So then after the user presses the button and the user interface detects it
what's the, what's the next thing that you expect would happen?
>> So I think that the next things that are hap,
going to happen are going to be all of our checks to start the brew process.
So we're- >> Make, makes sense.
>> Mm-hm. Check if the water's there, check if our receptacles in place.
>> Okay, so there's, there's two primary checks.
Do we have, you know, have we loaded up the water, and then, do we have a,
a coffee pot to hold the results of, you know, the coffee after we've brewed it.
So those are two checks.
Is does it matter which one we do first?
>> I don't think so.
Not necessarily.
>> Okay. >> Just as long as they're all held.
>> And so, I, I don't see either.
And so, we're not going to be concerned about that.
At that point things are ready.
We can, we can start the boiler to produce some hot water.